GREG AVOLA: Hi everybody.
Good afternoon.
Thanks for having me today.
We're going to talk about
something that's very dear to
my heart, and it looks like
it is for you too.
And that is the love of beer.
So let's get started
with Untappd.
So first of all, who am I?
My name is Greg Avola.
I'm the co-founder and
CTO of Untappd.
We're based out of New
York and Los Angeles.
We're actually doing this
in a part time basis.
I'm a New York City resident,
but I'm a die
hard Red Sox fan.
So I apologize if anyone
is offended by that.
We sucked last year.
You guys made the playoffs.
At least give me some break.
I specialize in PHP and
JavaScript and MySQL, which is
the technology stack from some
part of it for Untappd.
My claim to fame is I
was on Man Versus
Food for nine seconds.
I had a great cameo.
I'm going to show it to you
right now, because this is
amazing stuff.
OK?
[INAUDIBLE]
That's it.
Thank you.
It was an Oscar winning
performance.
I still get text messages from
day from friends like at 2:00
in the morning when
this re-airs.
It's pretty funny,
but that's all.
So first off--
next slide here--
so what is Untappd?
Untappd is a social discovery
tool for your iPhone, Android,
and pretty much any device.
It allows you to do a
lot of cool things--
track your beers, see what your
friends are having, rate,
and most important discover,
which is what we're all about.
More important parts of Untappd
is being able to
encourage your realm of beer
to a different state.
So you would normally drink one
beer over and over again,
but you're a little bit afraid
of branching out.
What Untappd helps to do is make
the drinking experience
more social into
a web presence.
So there's a Twitter and
Facebook for certain
activities, but we focus on
beer, which is a very social
activity but never really
in a web presence.
One of the key features
of ONTAP Untappd
is the sharing ability.
When you check in on Untappd,
we use Foursquare for all of
our locations.
So basically, a user can check
in a beer and attach the
location that they're actually
using and then
share that with friends.
You can push that to Twitter,
Facebook, and back to
Foursquare as well so you don't
have to open up too many
apps at once.
Because we all know that the
most important thing when
drinking a beer is drinking
the beer.
So that's really what
it's all about.
Discovery is a big important
part, like I mentioned before.
One of the things that we
introduced in our newest app
that came out last year, is the
ability to discover new
places and beers for you.
This goes along the lines of
if you went to a bar and
you're not exactly sure what
they have there, the app can
recommend beers based on what
your friend is drinking, what
has been checked into that
location in the last 30 days--
that's the average state of a
beer from a keg perspective--
and also based on the ecosystem
of the app.
So if a beer is very popular
over the last 30 days, it'll
push it to the top.
As you can see in these
screenshots here, these are
from Oregon, where we were
at a conference recently.
And you can see some of the
top venues that are going.
This is really cool if you go
to a new city for the first
time and you want to see where
the happening spots are around
the block that serve
beer that you like.
It can sort of filter
to your methodology.
We also have maps to show you
where your friends are.
Don't abuse this feature.
It's a friendly feature.
If they're completely wasted,
it's not a very good thing to
look for them, try
to find them, and
play around with them.
But the key part is that you
find your friends and make it
more social, because what
Untappd means to do is making
drinking a much more
social activity.
A little about us from a
community prospective from
stats, we have around 400,000
users that are registered in
our service in about
two years.
And we have 21 million
check-ins.
So as you can see, not a huge
user base but a very dedicated
user base that likes
to drink a lot of
different types of beer.
It's really cool.
We average around 3,000
check-ins per hour.
We have around 20,000 social
shares per day.
So that's sharing to Facebook,
or Twitter, or Foursquare.
When someone shares to Twitter
or Facebook, we track their
follower count so that we can
see what the total reach is.
So we reach around 7.3 million
people per day.
And we also a feature in our
app that allows you to take
pictures of the beer
that you're having.
And on average, weekly total
over 35,000 photos uploaded of
beer related photos.
I must stress that.
So that's really cool for
a small start-up like
ourselves--
only two people and
self funded.
It's pretty cool.
So this is really cool.
Apps are awesome.
But what are you trying
to solve here?
What is the business
proposition?
Was is Untappd really
aiming to do?
So we have a couple of things,
and I'll break them into three
different points where we think
we can help a lot of
people with the consumer side
and also the business side.
The first and foremost, this is
a picture of Russian River
out in California.
I labeled it as WTF, because
if I'm a new user are not
really know about beer, I look
at this list and I'm like,
what am I supposed to have?
I have no clue which beer I'm
going to like based on my
previous style of taste.
I don't know my friend
is drinking.
I'm totally confused.
All these beers are phenomenal
by the way, if you haven't had
a chance to try them.
But from a new user prospective,
Untappd aims to
help you make a decision.
And when you're at the bar,
it is, what should I have?
What are my friends having?
What will I like before
I buy it?
Because you don't want to have
to return the beer afterwords,
because it never really works.
On the business side, we want
to give breweries an
opportunity to expose
their product.
Now, this is a typical picture
of a package store or a liquor
store where you see this big
mounds of the big beer, the
big macrobreweries out there.
You see some microbreweries in
the corner and the back, but
at the same time, they don't
have the placement.
They don't have the money.
They don't have the advertising
to push their
product to the front.
And what Untappd helps to do
is, by people sharing and
checking into their beer,
they're marketing for them.
So it's an opportunity for them
to get a level playing
field in the social front.
Also, location is a really big
thing when it comes to beer.
Because beer isn't distributed
everywhere in the United
States and even in the world,
trying to find a particular
beer that you really like
is very, very difficult.
Your friends can tell you
where they are and what
they're drinking.
And that can give you a diary
or a log of where beer is
around the city.
Every check-in is attached to
a geo-located point, so by
nature of doing some algorithms
and some math, you
can figure out really where the
beer is, who had it, and
how long ago it was had.
So you can get a good idea
of where the beer is.
And that can help you with
recommendations too.
By building out your
recommendation engine, you can
basically figure out what beers
are available in your
particular area as opposed to
more global recommendation,
but you can't get that beer.
So some of things that we offer
breweries in the form of
tools, are brewery accounts,
where are the breweries can
actually manage their page,
their inventory and see a
little bit of what we call
analytics on the stats of
their beers.
Now, it's this is kind of
revolutionary, to use a the
term that's really
overused a lot.
But breweries sell to
distributors in the US.
And distributors sell to bars.
So they don't really have an
insight on who their users
are, or what they're drinking,
or where, or what time.
All they know is the distributor
says, I need
another two cases of beer.
I sold two cases last week.
So we're given them a real
time look into their
statistics on a check-in, which
represents a revenue
booster for them so they can
see it in real time.
Also, to give them a list of
what their top beers are, but
also give them places, and
styles, and what have you.
Also, managing your online
profile for a beer company is
very tedious.
There are a lot of sites out
there that don't offer a lot
of good tools to help you kind
of manage your [INAUDIBLE]
file correctly--
add the correct IBU, the ABV,
all these acronyms that they
need to fix to make sure that
everything is accurate.
We give them really cool tools
to help them do that.
We also give them an
important feature,
which I like the most.
It's the ability to toast and
comment on people's check-ins.
Now, toast is our version of
like, for Facebook, or a +1.
Is basically allows
the breweries to
say, hey, good job.
We like you checking
into our beer.
We can also comment and say,
how did you like it?
Did you have it with
some food?
These are really important
features for breweries because
they can never really
communicate with the customer
or the user on a
regular basis.
When you're at a bar and I have
a beer or a Bronx Pale
Ale or something like that,
Bronx Brewery can comment
directly to me and say,
how did you like it?
And that's a really
good communication
tool between the two.
So here are some examples of
some breweries that have done
this both in the US and
outside the US.
On the right hand side, we have
Sixpoint, which is really
active on our service.
They communicate a lot.
You get a lot of interaction
with individuals.
You can get some insights.
We had one brewery that released
a batch of beer, and
a lot of negative comments
on Untappd.
They figured out that it was
because the bar wasn't
cleaning their tap line.
So through that information,
they can go back to the bar
and say, hey, last seven
check-ins has given us a
really bad rating, but they said
it was really good in the
previous times they had it.
What's going on?
So we can use these tools
to better serve the
customers and whatnot.
And the best thing about our
service is just like
Foursquare, we have badges for
achieving awesomeness when it
comes to beer.
So we offer these badges
both as a [INAUDIBLE]
for Untappd users to unlock,
such as drinking 1,000 unique
beers, which has been
done multiple times.
And doing certain activities,
like having a beer at a music
venue or at a bowling alley.
Gamification comes to the
beer world in a fun way.
But also for the breweries, it
gives them an opportunity to
promote their own products
as well.
Here are some examples of some
badges we've done for
breweries and for beer weeks.
On the top left, that's Karl
Strauss celebrating their
anniversary.
Users can check-in Karl Strauss
beer during their
anniversary time period.
They would unlock this badge.
We did one for Bridgeport, which
is out of Oregon, and LA
Beer Week, and the other
ones as well.
So it's a great opportunity
to incentivize the brewery
industry to think outside the
typical advertising realm.
You put an ad on a page or in a
newspaper, it's very static.
With Untappd, it's more
action based.
You have to go out and check-in
or try the beer.
And we're finding people will
drive state to state looking
for a beer to unlock a badge.
I had a friend of mine from
California trade four beers
and a Nintendo Game Boy
mint condition for a
beer to get a batch.
That's crazy, but it happens.
And these are a cool for people
to encourage to try
different things.
And once you try something as
we all know, we become a fan
of it and learn more about it.
So it's a good way to do that.
So with this, we have over
2,000 breweries that have
already claimed their
profile on Untappd.
Here are some big ones
to be named--
New Belgium, Dogfish
Head, Deschutes--
all interacting with customers
today on Untappd and also
interacting with other breweries
as well to see how
they're doing across
the board.
So it's a really cool thing
for them to try out.
But with every service, you got
to have apps, because apps
is the only cool thing.
Because if you don't
have an app, you're
not really a service.
So I want to shift the
discussion a little bit to
tour what our apps are like and
how we got there with our
small development team.
So first thing starting out, we
built the product back in
October of 2010, so about two
years and a couple months.
We started out with
a basic principle.
We thought maybe it would be
cool to actually check in our
beer, share with friends.
And we wanted to make that
on a mobile platform.
To be honest, my co-founder
came up
with the idea of Untappd.
I told him, I don't think anyone
is going to do this.
It's probably a waste of time.
I was completely wrong
with that.
So we started out with the
only thing we knew.
We're two web developers.
We said HTML5.
Let's do it.
Let's try it.
Let's get a prototype out there,
and let's really work
on trying to get this
in that direction.
So we started with HTML5 app.
The cool thing was, that worked
on day one on a lot of
platforms--
iOS, BlackBerry, WebOS, Android,
everybody really on
day one from the browser.
That was great because there
are a lot of apps out there
that had similar things, but
they are only on one platform.
There wasn't really any
on Android at all.
There are a lot on iOS
but nothing really
on the Android front.
So it was great to explore
the multiple platforms.
When we first built it,
there was something
called jQuery Mobile.
There was Seneca Touch.
But they weren't really in
the stable environment.
So we actually built our own
custom framework to support
these different pages
in this web app.
And then we had social
integration on day one--
the ability to share, to
Twitter, Facebook, which is
pretty standard nowadays but
back then those helped us
really grow the ecosystem of
the users and to get them
excited about earning badges.
A little piece of trivia when
we first did Untappd, every
single badge unlocked
with one check-in.
So we had a the top of the
morning badge, which was drink
before 12:00 PM--
one check-in.
So we launched the service
in the morning.
People would try it out and
get like 15 badges.
And they'd be like, oh wow.
This is great.
So we had to scale that down a
little bit as we learned a
little bit through the system.
So as Untappd grew,
it was awesome.
We were seeing all this organic
growth of our user accounts.
It was amazing.
That little dip right there is a
Mashable post at 2:00 in the
morning eastern time.
That was not good for servers.
So that was interesting.
We're slowly growing and
everything is fantastic, but
we have a problem.
The problem is, that apps--
everyone wants native apps.
They want to be able
to download things.
They want to be able to have
it on their phone on their
home screen.
You can do that really easily
with a web app.
The common knowledge
isn't right there.
The basic problem, people
couldn't find us.
They couldn't find us at all.
I'd go to a bar to try to
encourage people to use it.
And the first question
they'd ask you is,
how do I get Untappd?
And we said, open
up your browser.
And they'd go, what?
Open up your browser.
I don't have a browser.
I have app store.
I have Google Play.
No, go to your Safari, your
Chrome, or whatever.
And you lost them.
They couldn't find you.
So we had this big
problem about web
apps and native apps.
We tried to bridge that gap.
The second thing is, native
development is very, very hard
for us, for web developers that
don't really know the
language that well.
We have to learn
something new.
And that's something that we
just didn't have the resources
and time to do.
And finally, we're
self funded.
Money is awesome.
It's the biggest superpower
in the world.
The problem is, we
didn't have any.
We're just paying our rent.
It's pretty hard to do anyways
in New York City.
So we thought to ourself,
what we do here?
We have these pros and cons
for native and mobile.
How are we going to bridge the
gap and be able to provide a
good experience by using native
functionality, such as
the camera and other features,
but still be able to develop
apps to be able to
support them?
So on the pro side, it was
really cool to be able to push
out new updates right off
the bat with HTML5.
But we lack features like
discoverability and camera,
which are now available in some
versions of OSs, but back
when we started, they
weren't there.
So our solution was PhoneGap.
And PhoneGap allows us to do
everything we just talked
about and access native
functionality and still make
the app move really fast.
So there are a lot of
solutions out there.
And this is the version of our
app running on Android--
actually a new version that's
going to be coming out
probably in the next week.
And why do we choose PhoneGap
over the other ones?
It was quite simple.
PhoneGap allows us to develop an
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript,
and then put all that in a
wrapper, and then build
plug-ins on top of that to
support native features.
There's other stuff that are
similar to this out there.
But they require you to use your
own object types, your
own data types.
This was the simplest
for us to do.
And it produced the best
results that we had.
So we basically took our
mobile web app, and we
converted over to a PhoneGap
app probably in two hours.
And it was fantastic.
It was running in all
of our phones.
We were really, really
excited.
The problem is, that we need to
make it customizable to the
level of UI patterns for
each individual phone.
So as you can see in the Android
version, we keep a
very similar style to what you
guys have of more of an action
bar on the top.
On our iOS version, we flip it
over to have more of a bottom
bar navigation.
So those are the things we learn
throughout the entire
process to really build your
UI around what the app
actually is.
One of the cool things is the
plug-in feature of PhoneGap.
You can actually access native
things like for example, in
iOS, you can access the action
sheet, which is the piece that
brings up bottom bar.
You touch on those things as
well and still not write an
ounce of native code.
So it was a really good
opportunity for us.
Well, how did it work?
Did it work well for us?
Well, you see these
jumps here.
And the day we released
our PhoneGap app
version two, huge spike.
It was ridiculous.
It was pretty awesome.
We were really excited
about that.
And then as you go see later on,
we did another version, a
version update on the
right hand side.
And it still went up again.
So as you continue to build your
product and build your
design, we found out things we
could do to tweak it and make
it more interesting.
And PhoneGap for us
really helped
us bridge that platform.
So some of the cool things is
that on the first month that
we did it, we ranged 25,000
users on the first month we
released our native app.
We were averaging around 4,000
users a month previous to
that, so it was a huge jump.
We increased check-ins
by 300%, which was
crazy for us to see.
And then my wife told me that
we are on the top 50 apps in
the app store in iOS.
I don't believe her, I think
she's lying to me to make me
feel better, but she says it was
true so I'm going to put
it in the slide deck.
But yeah, we really love
PhoneGap, the ability to
connect with these multiple
interfaces.
We've been really big on
HTML5 and web apps.
We think that's the future
of apps out there.
I think that a lot of browsers
out there help us get to that
realm, and this was the
best vehicle to get
there from that avenue.
So I want to shift a little
bit to fun stats about
Untappd, because as we all know,
if you're a data junkie,
you love beer, a lot of
interesting stuff can come out
of data that we're generating.
It shows interesting trends on
what we're doing, and what the
industry is doing, what the
consumer base is doing.
First, I want to go on the
technology stack around
Untappd and what we're
actually all about.
So first, we're a traditional
LAMP stack--
Linux, Apache, MySQL, PHP.
We use CodeIgniter for all
of our app framework.
So that powers our API,
which we'll talk about
a little bit later.
And also, our mobile apps are
all written in HTML5, but
they're all powered
by the API itself.
We use Redis in memcache, which
has been a lifesaver,
specifically for accounts.
So every beer on Untappd, every
time it gets checked in,
the account gets increased
by one.
So we store it to Redis for a
fast memory database reads.
Amazon S3 we use for all of
our static files-- so
JavaScript, mainly our
assets, but more
importantly, our photos.
Every time a photo gets uploaded
to Untappd from the
actual app, we store four
versions of that file.
We store large, small,
medium, thumbnail.
And all that good stuff
gets stored in S3.
We use Rackspace cloud for
all of our hosting needs.
We got an email yesterday from
them saying that we are now
one of their--
we have like two dedicated
account reps for us.
And I don't know how
that's possible.
We must be paying a lot of
money for them somehow.
And then we use Amazon Cloud
Search, which is a pretty new
technology for us for all
of our searching needs.
Beer and brewery search can be
very difficult, because you go
down to local bar, they're going
to call Brooklyn Ale,
which does not exist
as a beer.
It's Brooklyn Lager.
But people have the
wrong names.
So you really need a fundamental
way of trying
adding aliases to beers so it
could be searchable so that no
more duplicates are
in the system.
It's actually funny that we
did that because we have a
team of super users, around 40
volunteers, that go through
the database and they
merge duplicates.
We have a free opening editing
system for beers, so you can
add whatever you like.
So people have taken whatever
they want to do and made
beers out of it.
My favorite one is water
by the brewery, Earth.
That was a good one.
We have Dr. Pepper in there
and interesting stuff
all over the place.
So we rely a lot on our
moderators to help us merge
and consolidate that.
A lot of beer sites keep this
close minded view of like,
we'll approve the beers.
And you guys don't
know anything.
But it's really open.
It allows people to add a
lot of stuff in there.
So we're not as big as Google,
so these numbers shouldn't
shock you, but for me, they
shocked me when I saw them.
But in every given month, we're
transferring about 2.8
terabytes of data just to
our database alone.
That's all of our queries, all
of our media, all of our
assets, everything
back and forth.
So this is all beer-related
terabytes of data.
That's pretty crazy.
Two million beer-related, as
I stress, photos have been
uploaded to Untappd
in about a year.
So we're averaging on the
weekends around 16,000 to
17,000 photos uploaded.
When we first implemented this
feature, I thought to myself,
maybe I'll take a picture of a
beer because it's kind of fun.
And I won't do it very often.
And now I'm taking it
all the time, and I
can't understand why.
I think everyone wants to take
pictures of what they're
drinking to brag.
It's just like food.
People take pictures of food,
it's like better than yours.
But beer is in a glass.
And it's usually the same color
than your friends'.
How are they going to know
what the picture is of?
Hey, people do want
they want to do.
So that's the way it is.
People usually don't actually
share the beer
they drink the most.
So the top graph shows what the
people share the most--
the Lagunitas, Guinness, Winter
Lager, Yuengling, and
Bell's Hopslam, which is
a really double IPA.
But then the one on the bottom
is what they usually have.
So we have Guinness and
Lagunitas, which match.
Then we have Bud Lite, Winter
Lager, and Miller Lite.
So basically, you're not sharing
what you're actually
drinking, because you're ashamed
of it most likely.
So that's probably what
it comes down to.
But it's a cool little stat that
I actually love to show
people, because people share the
stuff they want people to
be jealous of but not the fact
that they're the top 10
drinker of Miller Lite on tap.
Saint Patrick's Day is a
great, great day for
everything.
And this dog represents
everything there is about
Saint Patrick's Day.
Last year we wanted to really
push Guinness out there, but
we didn't have a really
good search engine.
We implemented this
after this.
So we found out doing an
algorithm that Guinness was
misspelled 2,500 times in our
database on the day of Saint
Patrick's Day.
There are iterations in there
that I cannot understand why
somebody would do this.
There's no G.
There's no U. What were
you spelling?
Were you just punching a
keyboard or something?
I'm not sure.
But it's a fun stat,
I have to say.
Since then, we've added almost
every iteration as an alias.
So now it comes up.
So this year we probably won't
have the same problem.
But there will be a lot of
people creating beers that
they don't even know what
existed because Saint
Patrick's Day.
So the average user on
Untappd drinks about
19 beers per month.
So you're averaging a little
under a beer a day.
That's pretty crazy.
I didn't realize that when
I was doing to that.
Nothing wrong with that--
keep checking in and
keep drinking beer.
But 19 beers a month.
That's a lot--
kind of like this fridge
over here.
So that's pretty crazy.
So when we first built our
database of beer, we used an
open source beer database with
around 5,000 entries.
And now today we're at 200,000
beers being entered
in about two years.
And actually more of those
have been entered--
around 250,000 total.
We do a lot of merges
and whatnot.
And this is crazy, because
we're averaging about 100
beers being created per day.
Now you have to understand there
are some home brews that
people enter in as well.
So there's not commercialized
beer, but we'd
still support them.
But 100 beers per day is pretty
crazy that you can
still get that kind of realm of
new beers being discovered
all the time, which is amazing,
because beer is fantastic.
So one of the things that I'm
really big on is open source
and allowing data to being
shared to everyone.
So if you have an idea for a
quick project, or if you want
to see some cool things,
or develop something.
We had some guy build a calorie
counter, which I don't
want to see ever when
it comes to beer.
I believe that data really
belongs to the world, so we
had an API since the day
one that we came
out, back in 2010.
So we have a full API that is
fully RESTful and all JSON.
So if you're interested in
hacking around one weekend,
you should check it out.
So with that, I recommend
to try Untappd if you
haven't done that.
It's available obviously
on the iPhone, Android.
We just released a product
for BlackBerry.
But with PhoneGap, like I said,
we're able to basically
put it on platforms
whenever we like.
So I advise you to start
drinking socially, because
drinking socially is the
best thing you can do.
And if you're at home drinking
alone, with Untappd you'll
never be alone again--
very simple.
So I guess at this point, I'll
open up for any questions.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
There's beer over there.
AUDIENCE: What are
your highest and
lowest rated beers?
GREG AVOLA: The highest rated
beer on our service is
actually the Goose Island
Bourbon County Stout.
It has a 4.7 out of 5.
We do an algorithm for ratings
similar to IMDB, so it's like
a weighted average.
But the lowest rated beer is,
I believe, commercially
related it's Miller Lite.
They have a 1.2 rating
on Untappd.
People hate that stuff.
I don't know why.
It's a--
An important thing too, Untappd
is all about craft and
whatnot but we're also
about everyone else.
So the four highest checked in
beers ever is Miller Lite, Bud
Light, Coors Lite, and Coors.
So those are the top
ever of all time.
So you can see that people are
still checking those in, but
after a while they're seeing
what their friends are
drinking, and they're changing
their habits.
And then a new user comes in
the very next day, and it
wipes it all clean again.
So you have to start over.
So people are still using the
service both on the craft side
and also on the macro side.
AUDIENCE: In relation to that,
do you see any evidence of
peoples' taste getting more
exciting as they use the app?
GREG AVOLA: Yes, absolutely.
One of my best friends from
college and also another
friend of mine from a previous
job, he was the fourth highest
drinker of Bud Lite
on the service.
I think he had over 400 or 500
check-ins to Bud Light.
[LAUGHTER]
He's going to kill me
for this story.
And one day, I saw him check-in
to a beer that I'd
had that I'd told them about.
And since then, he's not had
a single Bud Light ever.
And that was about three
or four months ago.
And I'm not up here because
I made fun of him so much.
Or maybe because he
actually found the
path to history there.
So it's really cool feature to
see that shift in paradigm
when it comes to styles of beer,
because after you check
in, the app recommends three
similar styles of beer.
So we're hoping that those
kind of take people on a
different path and try
to discover new beer.
Now, there's nothing wrong with
Bud Lite, or Miller Lite,
or any of those phenomenal beers
at all, but there are
other avenues out there
to explore.
And we hope that we
get that in there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is this ever going
to [INAUDIBLE]
something like wine?
GREG AVOLA: Yeah, actually
that's a question we get asked
a lot, is where is the fill
in the blank for Untappd.
We've got some crazy ideas--
cigars for Untappd.
Bike riding--
I don't know what that is all
about, but we've got that.
Wine is the next step that we
want to eventually go down.
We want to nail down the beer
piece first and get
that kind of set.
We've learned a lot
from that path.
I think that it doesn't really
belong with Untappd.
It belongs in a separate
ecosystem.
But altogether, it would
be one unique
flow, a different app.
But it's definitely something
that my wife wants to use.
She doesn't even like
beer that much.
She's like, where is Uncorkd
man, where is it?
It's actually a wine magazine,
so they already own the domain
and everything.
Is definitely something that
we're interested in doing.
AUDIENCE: I know you write
your files in HTML5.
[INAUDIBLE] moved away from
doing HTML5 in a web-based
[INAUDIBLE].
Do you think you'll reach
that point at some
point in the scale?
[INAUDIBLE]?
GREG AVOLA: I think the whole
debate on HTML5, if you've
actually inspected some of their
code, they're actually
hitting m.facebook.com inside
their app and pulling in all
of the raw HTML and JavaScript
and then re-rendering it in
the browser.
That's pretty slow.
You're going to see a lot of
performance hit there.
We did the same thing when
we first launched.
And we found out that that
wasn't the ideal solution.
So now what we do is we do all
the templating rendering on
the client side as opposed to
rendering on the server and
then passing it back to you.
I think there will be a point
eventually that we might want
to go native.
But HTML5 is working
pretty well for us
considering what we have.
And we're excited about
the features.
The main thing is, what's
great about the Android
browser when doing these things
is that you're allowed
to have the same level of
JavaScript rendering that you
do on your standard browser.
But on iOS side, because they
limit the developer
interaction on the web view,
you really don't have that
same level of rendering.
So hopefully they get
their act together.
We'll be happy people.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
for your mobile website
[INAUDIBLE]?
GREG AVOLA: Yes.
Basically what we do is,
PhoneGap will preach that you
can use one code base across
multiple platforms.
That works, and you could
definitely do that.
For us, we separated it out.
And basically we build
a feature.
And then we apply it to
one template library.
We use handelbar.js for all
of our template engine.
And we'll fix it on one
of those repos.
And then we'll just replicate
it across the board.
And then we'll push those
and build them together.
So it's really quick
development.
It's not like I say I want to
build a feature into iOS and
then say, oh, well then two
months later I'm going to have
to build a feature
into Android.
I can do it all at once at the
same time, which helps us.
We actually really only release
updates to both
platforms on the same day.
So if there is an iOS release,
then we'll release Android.
I always hated when people
were like, Android gets
everything first, iPhone
gets everything--
We don't do that stuff.
We just say, everything out
on the same day and phone
[INAUDIBLE] to help us
get to that level.
AUDIENCE: So what's the
motivation strategy to you to
[INAUDIBLE]?
GREG AVOLA: Right now, the
analytics are free.
We do some advertising with the
badges, which is a form of
advertisement.
I think what we want to do
eventually if we want to be
able to help breweries connect
better with their customers.
As I said earlier, they don't
have the demographics on what
their actually age breakdown,
state breakdown, location
breakdown, of where their
beer is being sold.
A lot of craft and even big
micro or macro breweries spend
millions and millions
of dollars
on these focus groups--
people telling them, OK, how
is the beer tasting?
Where we have a service that
does it for you freeingly
without them having to
pay the focus groups.
And we fire that back to
you in analytics forms.
So I guess once we get the
amount of data that I think is
relevant for them to make a
decision, I think this could
used for marketing decisions
and a lot of
other stuff as well.
And it doesn't really stop
at just breweries too.
Venues and bars could also use
this data as well to better
serve their clients.
AUDIENCE: We're going to ask
about a little bit about the
search function, because it's
probably [INAUDIBLE]
in using it.
I'm just curious why-- and I'm
not an engineer so there might
be an obvious answer here-- but
why doesn't it return a
suggestion when you misspell?
Anything would be helpful
in some cases.
GREG AVOLA: Yeah, we're working
on that for another
release for our app.
When we first moved off of a
basic regular search, our
cloud search from Amazon doesn't
provide "did you
mean?" Which doesn't
really help us
when that comes together.
So we tried to avoid that by
adding a lot of aliases for
common misspelled words.
So we have a job that runs on a
monthly basis and basically
checks to see, versus the
queries, versus what was
returned, to see if
there's a match.
So we can figure out what those
are, and we add them in.
So that when you spell Sixpoint
with a space in
between or especially without
a space, it gets it right.
But we definitely want
to add that in there.
It's a highly requested
feature.
AUDIENCE: Some of the breweries,
obviously, their
names are not that
search friendly.
GREG AVOLA: Right.
Another thing people talk about
is barcode scanners for
actually picking up the bottles,
which is great.
But I have this suspicion that
most people are drinking in
draft beers.
And that you can't
do, not even with
technology to see the beer.
It's not going to be able
to tell you what it is.
Searching is definitely
something that we want to work
on and get better.
We're very early in
the development.
But you should have seen it
when we first started.
It was horrible--
so bad.
You could type in Coors, and it
would come up with nothing.
AUDIENCE: What is your
favorite badge?
GREG AVOLA: Favorite badge is,
I got married this past year
in September, and my co-founder
put in a surprise
badge for the wedding.
And I was thrilled.
I was actually flipping out when
I saw it, because I do
all development on my side.
I don't know how the hell he
went to the database to put in
without unlocking to the
entire community.
So that was pretty cool.
But when I saw it, I
was really excited.
That's probably the
best badge ever.
But besides that, I have to say
the Take It Easy badge for
taking in, I think it's
12 beers in 24 hours.
I'm not encouraging binge
drinking whatsoever at all.
OK?
But if you're at a festival or
a sampler, these are the
things that you get
those badges.
And it's pretty cool.
Someone told us we should to do
a cab badge, so when that
unlocks, it automatically calls
the yellow cab and gets
you a cab there.
That would be funny.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: So you were saying
you do this part time?
GREG AVOLA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you hope that this
will eventually become a
full-time gig?
Or are you happy with this
as a part-time job?
GREG AVOLA: I hope to God it
becomes a full-time thing,
because I don't sleep anymore.
And it's just ridiculous.
I really hope that one day we'll
be able to take this
full time and go down
that route.
I think that we have a solid
business plan and a solid
group of customers and users.
And one day maybe that will
turn into a full-time gig.
We're just chugging along
now, hopefully.
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Do you have a list
of beers over there
so I can check in?
GREG AVOLA: Yes, they're
actually on the top--
just like searching.
They're horrible, you can't
really read them.
We do have a list.
I think we can provide it.
I believe it's the Lagunitas
Pilsner.
It's the Peak Organic
Winter Session.
There is a chocolate beer,
I believe, over there.
AUDIENCE: Racer 5.
GREG AVOLA: Racer 5, which
I highly recommend if you
haven't had that one,
which is an IPA.
Double White from Southampton,
which is a wheat beer.
They're all in Untappd.
And if you spell it right,
you'll be golden.
You guys need to offer
an API, autosuggest.
That's what you guys
need to do.
And I'll be fine.
AUDIENCE: There used
to be a 15 minute--
don't ask me how I know--
GREG AVOLA: You're
an early adopter.
That's why you know.
AUDIENCE: Was that there
for a liability issue?
GREG AVOLA: At first, we didn't
really know what this
would play out.
The first time we released it
with a 30 minute interval
between check-ins.
And we're like, yeah, no one
is going to do that.
It'll be fine.
And it was like, what
is wrong with you?
30 minutes?
I down a beer in five minutes.
What's wrong with you?
So we had to change it to 15.
It went 15 to 10.
And we said, screw it.
We just removed it altogether.
It was more of a legal thing.
We didn't know if someone would
check in too much, and
then it would be liable.
But we crossed that bridge.
And we're all with that.
But yeah, it really was to
try to slow down abuse.
We do have, just like
Foursquare, we do have people
that go out and they'll check-in
a million beers just
to get badges--
jumpers, as they call
them in Foursquare.
And we have the same ones
on our service as well.
So we didn't want anyone to
abuse the service and just
check in over and over again.
So we have that restriction.
Now, we've made it a
little bit better.
AUDIENCE: Since you're here at
Google, is there anything you
wish that Google would do with
the Android or anything to
make you life easier?
GREG AVOLA: It's funny
that you ask that.
I'm going to be completely
frank.
It's what I do.
Android, there are so many
different variants of Android
operating system and so many
different browsers that it
makes it hard to debug.
I'll give you a classic example,
the HTC Resound.
It's the phone with
Dr. Dre headsets.
Verizon pushed an update
for Ice Cream Sandwich.
And in the standard browser, it
will not open the keyboard
if you tap any text area.
And I went out and bought my
own one and tested it out.
And the version that Verizon is
pushing is different than
the one that you guys have.
And it works fine on the
one I have but not on
the one they do.
And those kind of things
are so weird.
And then the customer, the user
will be like, well, it
works in Chrome fine.
But I have four browsers
on my phone right now.
I have the regular browser.
I have Chrome.
I have something else.
So there's a lot of differences
between the two.
So making that standard browser,
either making it
Chrome, or getting rid of it, or
improving it to make it the
same level of Chrome would
be very helpful.
In all honesty, though, Android
is easy to develop
for, because I don't jump
through all these hoops to
push my app out there.
When I'm done with it, it's
there and it's on the store.
As opposed to waiting weeks,
and weeks, and weeks to get
things to go into the store.
I love Google, though.
Nothing is wrong with it.
AUDIENCE: Does PhoneGap help
with that situation at all?
GREG AVOLA: I find myself fixing
bugs with PhoneGap
because of these situations.
So I'm able to pass information
back to them.
PhoneGap is now owned by Adobe,
so they have a lot more
resources now to help us
solve these problems.
But we're mainly telling
them that our
users have these problems.
And they're trying to fix
them on their end.
And then we're helping together
to help fix those.
But for the most part, we're
dealing with a web view.
So the web view controls the
interaction between our elements.
So if you can't do it in a
standard website, then it will
not work in PhoneGap.
In the example I gave, if you
open up the browser and you go
to Facebook and you type in
something in the text area,
your keyboard won't come up.
But if you use Chrome,
it will be fine.
So that's the difference between
the two browsers.
So we just report that stuff to
them, and we help work with
them to fix the native
side of the code.
One of the other things we
encounter a lot is typically
in Android when there's not a
lot of memory, you close the
processes that's running.
So we shift over
to the camera.
It's not a lot of memory will
kill our app, and then it will
come back and it will
basically be gone.
So we work with them to fix
some of the problems
with that as well.
AUDIENCE: I'm using Untappd for
the first time right now.
GREG AVOLA: Are you
going to give me a
bug report or something?
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious to
know when you connect with
Facebook why you guys ask for
permission to read items in
our Newsfeed.
GREG AVOLA: Read in
your Newsfeed?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GREG AVOLA: I don't know.
That's a good question.
We should probably
get rid of that.
But mainly what we should be
looking for is, we need your
email address, your birthday,
because we validate everyone
over the age of 21
in the country.
And we post to your actual--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what information that is
posted to Newsfeed.
GREG AVOLA: Yeah, we
don't read it.
I guarantee that.
But I could remove that.
I'll do it tonight.
Sorry about that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
GREG AVOLA: I can't
comment on that.
No, we haven't had anything
like that.
Hopefully, none of that
in the future.
What we try to encourage with
all of our users is drinking
responsibly.
It's actually printed on the
app when you load it up for
the first time on the
splash screen.
And we're all about drinking
socially and very responsibly.
So we try to promote that
as much as we can.
So you won't see any badges
like, double take it easy in
the future or something
like that.
It's not really what
we're all about.
AUDIENCE: Do you notice rating
drift throughout a session?
There's a bar uptown where we
used to rate your beers and
everything, and I always noticed
that my numbers would
drift up throughout the night.
GREG AVOLA: I actually pulled
a stat on that yesterday.
And I thought that
be the case.
I thought earlier, you'd
probably rate higher.
And lower, you don't know what
you're doing anymore.
So you just hit the buttons
and it works.
But actually it's consistent
across the board.
There's no deviation.
One thing I do recognize is that
on Untappd, Monday is the
worst day for Untappd of all,
which is pretty obvious,
because it's after
a long weekend.
If it's a holiday, Monday
is popping.
It's awesome.
It's thrilling.
But on Monday, usually you see
people either checking in
beers they've had previously
over the weekend or checking
in a beer saying, man,
I'm so hungover.
This is ridiculous.
Hair of the dog.
Hopefully it worked.
Yeah, that's usually
how it works.
Like other websites, we don't
have a period on weekends and
nights where we can take it
down for maintenance.
So we're at work all during
the day at other jobs.
So the only time we
can take it down--
we did some stats on this-- is
Tuesday morning at four.
And the only people that
actually get pissed off is
people in Australia.
And they're just like,
I'm sorry.
You're like a day ahead of us.
Give us a break.
Come on.
So that's the only time we can
really take it down without
affecting entire people.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GREG AVOLA: Well, thank
you very much.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for the questions.
And have some beer.